[Music]
it's not my business
okay let's go yeah okay guys sorry about
that i'm
good game shock thank you thank you
thank you houston bacon
i feel like every game i won was flag we
should do we should probably do incoming
next time from the start
daniel is struggling
[Music]
people are getting stronger man people
are getting stronger
people are getting no i it is bad it is
it is it is my fault that's the way i
play chess but
he also just has to be faster
big honor thank you thank you
okay let's take um
yep it is blitz
okay let's focus five baby knight four
knight c4
sub only yeah perfect i'm gonna focus
great yes
again guys i'm not angry or anything
if i'm losing a couple of games
the best thing to do is sometimes this
is fine
just enjoy the match and it'd be okay
it's not always necessary to diagnose
let's go
deep reason for it you're losing other
than
he's playing better
i will go usually six i blended this
move
although fortunately i have this
okay now he's going after me
oh what exactly is the idea if i go
rugby one though
i feel like he has something i don't
know i don't see what it is
okay rugby one okay i could connect a
three check
um h1
knight e4 c4 but okay i will although
for
eight and a four i don't see it okay i
mean i want to go okay knight f3
h1 knight d4 c4
rogue b8 so he wants prophylaxis against
c4 obviously
but what if it should be two
queen f6 knight f4 is good
and he missed this move
okay so i'm 30 seconds up which is
basically even time as i refer to
bishop e2 saves the knight i don't know
what he's oh actually no it doesn't
wait bishop e2 and bishop d4 c3 though
okay 94 thank you jessica
okay we're going to do obviously yeah he
found a way to save the night
i was surprised he didn't do this
immediately
like the clocks are frozen
right
[Music]
okay
thank you mookie
thank you for the 100 where'd it go
92 is the move only move only move is
92.
otherwise white is worse
okay that was very very nice game
i mean i i was about to choke it but
then i
got lucky there in the tactics
hilarious thing would be if magnus
accepted now that's not the move
because of h6 and knight f6 i think
that's the idm
yeah this is like this all of this i
know black should be slightly better
here because
it can well maybe it's equal rook d1
equal probably
equal
okay rook d1 so i don't have to rush
with taking like actually kind of do
rook d5 otherwise he goes rook c1 and
then i'm in trouble
so this is should be six i guess just
develop the bishop with tempo
this is all very normal so i'm playing
fast
and now rook ac 8 he probably wins the
pawn
f5 looks very tempting here
and 5 looks good
just going for the advantage here
oh i'm down okay so f4 doesn't doesn't
do anything
thank you 100 mormon i'm down two
minutes
probably i should play v6 to cover
prepare
let's go here okay see one maybe it's
annoying
and i take take maybe one i will go
night
91 okay makes a lot
it's still probably equal honestly
i don't think i'm better
i'm going to lose bunch of ratings
tonight so it doesn't matter
let's go roxy for to compel him to take
hey
bishop c3 takes
i shouldn't have allowed any of this
thank you rash daddy no thank you guys
thanks um 93
okay i got to disable the alerts though
thank you
thank you pandora tangled for three
months thanks for
hanging there tango rook d2
dania is going to flag me so bad here
so unfairly
should probably push our phones negative
four
check i'm going to take their own
okay it goes there richie too
oh rook c2 is just winning
okay he can take but i don't think this
works
yeah king c2 yeah i'm losing go
thank you generalist sharing tone for
four months
you so much i need to pee also again
just bad i have to go after this game
oh yeah all right still here
another one in the can ladies and
gentlemen i have to play today for
go here
here
knight is three are you gonna fight
maybe
knight e5 hmm that's a weird move
okay should be slightly better here
thank you dr lonno for three months
thank you so much
dr luno
okay five is the question if i bishop e3
should be six
let's go bishop g5 let's not bother
okay so now the couple of things here
i don't like the placement of this rook
let's get this back
civilization i should play a5 to freeze
the pawns but i don't really see what
that does either
you could also go h3 let's just play a
calmly h3 just
crazy six takes okay he allowed f4
i can also take f6 and go queen g4 but
probably not a good idea to give up the
bishops for that
okay let's preemptively go here this
group yay
thanks
27 i
could go i can't of course go rookie 2
but
27 sucks
because queen g3 and they sound great um
how can i be clown she's 27 i'll go
queen g3
i think looking afraid probably king ffa
wow that's a pretty bold move i see what
he wants he wants to stack the pawn like
that
i don't trust that at all though
okay d1 is possible
queen h6 bishop p3 maybe bishop b3
queen b6
i'm not sure what to do here
i guess i'll go here goes
there should be six i'm playing
bad now i mean queen eight [ __ ]
rookie three probably
rookie three dinks
there there there rook 81
takes takes
probably i should just go here um it
goes there i could
take it takes i'll probably take the
bishop honestly no but if i take it the
rook takes two it's a
raw at the best for me so
not sure about that i'll take the bishop
here bishop before is what i missed but
it's okay
am i getting some quicker losing
position after this maybe i don't know
well but now i would
put this body here
okay
should be six is a thread obviously
let's give it a check conor's a rock
give it a check first
of course let's give a check first
i mean i saw that that was why i moved
this truly check first yeah
okay thanks bishop g5
just to check first
okay everything bishops before
supporting oops
no no no no no no no no oh my
that was a mouse slip ladies and
gentlemen but it's okay it's not the
worst one in the world
i i think it's a move but
whoops and i like
blaze like me and that's the only thing
that could have gone wrong at this
moment
is a mouse slip okay it's legal it's not
terrible it's not
i've now slipped worse before so let's
try to get out of this situation
how should we it's so such a sloppy
thing to do
and i like to hurt my finger
nervousness okay
oh h5 okay
that's odd no it's not so bad
i don't think it's so bad but it is not
good that way when the bishop moves it's
always
covers the square it used to be no this
is very bad actually
you you you use
yeah oh not
really a clot into my finger
castle
you should be five take
why are you down three zeros in
naraditsuki because now this is very
strong man
knight c4 i didn't think that this was
scary because of f6
rook c1
okay so b6 i guess just to solidify
one yeah and maybe get the knight around
but i don't think so
f5 is also no no five is bad
should probably bring the king in at
least
a little bit i can adopt him easily but
that's the problem he's not 2700
that is the little problem if you fix
that then it's fine
um let's go bishop d2
i want to take on beef okay now let's
try to get the knight around to d6
bishop c3
i walked into f4 though right into this
[ __ ] g2
yeah this is losing though there's too
many
um there's too much stuff going on
big points from magnus good to daniel
they're not too much stuff
that mouse left killed me unfortunately
in here oh wow he doesn't do it now he
gives me a chance to get active though
hmm go here
is not good and did you first play
daniel he seemed like
four years ago it's so difficult to make
a move here
i see maybe no maybe less than that
maybe three years ago
first time
i don't know if he was playing on play
chess
uh the chess basically i
yeah this is a very rough game because
of the stupid little mousetraps
okay daniel okay
you fight now you played a good
positional game it's three
although it's not over here you go d6
kind of ass though you might want to
mate you don't know
just push i've seen crazier things
happen because
siri i think it's winning
i'm not sure if it is me but
yeah now he's kicking my king
it's funny how long i was able to stay
afloat i'll be right back guys please
tell him i'll be right back
okay we'll be back probably soon
all right let's continue
the developer okay yeah i don't think he
created the site that's true
benjamin that was a good one actually i
almost believed it who could mr b
i would have been crestfallen american
player it can be
okay guys guys let's focus now okay so
the question is
yeah let's go c3 i feel like this is
always better than superb
where did i walk into this
now b5 c4 that looks
scary as hell
nigel would not be 2900 um i'm not sure
29.79 yeah i don't think yeah yeah
that's true
is it hovel i don't know i would ditch
for magnus but we both would but 2008
how it was gm right yeah now i i
i played two passes later i think knight
c2 doesn't relate to of course i'm fine
here better than his gm
later but uh i'm i'm fine here but it's
not
not what i was looking for if 2008 it
was
game or not okay i'm going to go for the
iqp
because i can get my knight around to e3
that okay is
this is there his lines here but he is
good in good position
very good very bad okay
all right so there's taking his time
here
bishop h5 now we got to go after him
let's step on it
it was gm at 14 yeah
yes very good very bad crazy he's young
people man
no this has got to be bad for black it
has to be bad for a lot
it's like he's not developing anything
but i don't see it maybe e5 i take um
because there maybe not even maybe not
maybe it's not who knows
i guess it's not yeah
danny range is not the creator of jesus
okay let's let's at least try
bishop b7 i can play knight f7 and
rookie one
then rookie eight hmm probably not worse
it's such a danny operation
okay now we have to prevent him from
developing
let's go queen g4 h5 queen g5 i guess
b5 knight to six takes queen she's seven
okay he wants v5 obviously
obviously we need prophylaxis against b5
and a4 doesn't work
okay i have an idea
bishop c5 just goes like this that makes
a lot of sense i guess
i'm preparing some sort of a sacrifice
but i don't know which one yet
so what if i just take and go bishop f6
okay that obviously doesn't work
bishop f6 here is interesting
god i gotta play a part
opportunistically here
that's why he was never playing he's
definitely in confidence i'm not sure
it was so like no first of all nobody
was playing
on chess.com and second the design was
not great
so if i take now and go queen g5 he
moves his rook away
it's gotta be winning for me
i can also go rook d3 and rocket h3
very hard to say what to do
let's correct e3 i don't know
how is your day trending rock h3
obviously
you are in the same train
i'm just moving the pieces around
oh no no i'm not seeing some crazy
because i'm seeing blunder here
maybe
i have to be faster here
let's go here
let's exchange thank you ben type three
for the
oh thank you sir win this
normally
shoot
yeah it's i mean i yeah this time
scrambles are ridiculous
before that was a very tough one he had
like five seconds more than me
i even won a piece at some point
absolute insanity
i found every mode i'm not going to farm
again
i can't believe that i want a piece and
then instead of playing normally i lost
the pack
[Music]
maybe not even magnus i don't know
i can't i don't know what's wrong with
my time i don't even know what to do
about it i will take a little
time scrambles i played a lot completely
lost the ability to play them
yeah i don't think i will go back to
farming like 30 to 50.
i want to see what this looks like on
his end
all right he won the piece back in the i
blundered it in the only way possible
but whatever moving on
farming yeah it's a it's a nice lord oh
he's a much better bullet player than me
[Music]
and yet somehow when we play 32nd we're
pretty even i i
it's a completely negative i think he
got offline right yeah i've talked about
this before
i don't i don't get it at all
what if i try to hold the puns
it's so weird
94 no that was horrible
let's play like daniel against daniel
that's what i
more like what i expected
ship g5 bishop b7
takes pawn takes is interesting
we need
so complex
display like that yeah it's so smart
here
i have to take unfortunately with the
pawn
in order to avoid stuff along the e file
now i'm still two puns up though if i
can castle along i'll be good
but i'm just one tempo behind
wow really we're here yeah he's cooking
something up but i don't see it
just goes here okay so he's just playing
it he's just slow rolling it kind of
thing
i gotta get my king away there's no
choice
i have to get my king away
[Music]
may i miss that
how do you calculate that something
wait did i want to pick this or
no is that possible
yeah i wanted to take this of course
i think light is better here nothing
okay let's take it's not watered
alive it was a5 which is correct move i
think
massive one or something let's go f3
group five
hey
yeah that was so close to working
wait what if i go here
if we try something interesting
probably should go here still avoid
getting checkmated
yeah it's so slow
oh man i mean i can't
freaking survive in these time scrambles
i can basically resign if it's a time
scramble
okay now oh okay knight f6 equals e5
that
is that two now we gotta win another
three
here let's play the hedgehog
again the hedgehog
is the free phone bus
strokes you should pay for
how could i play like this bishop a4 you
should pay for and i'm good
it's just this is mind-boggling
absolutely mind-blowing
three two two but mine is twenty three
three oh three three okay it's three
three
okay yeah i throw the waves twenty or
eight and give me this three three
there you go
okay surprising
surprise he allowed us queen to get out
like this
if i go here you might i have to win
this one
not even a choice or else everything is
ruined
yes
yeah but again he finds a move
and again there's nothing
just insane
okay bishop before say if he goes rookie
two i go queen p7 knight cc
okay it goes there so 27
we got plans to release merchandise now
not for now
okay knight of five so let's see castle
castle i'm gonna try some stuff here i
take some sacrificial
let's do it yes let's just freaking take
i'm sure he's refuted it already in a
millisecond but
what can i do
oops another milestone i meant to play
rookie three
all right it just keeps happening
i meant to play rookie 3 and it grabs
the bishop it never happens anywhere
else
doesn't make sense this happened like a
bunch of times
am i seeing men's rook e3 i don't
understand why this happens all the time
that wasn't my sleep okay yeah
all right maybe i can decide okay
anyways i don't think i've made but yeah
he had chances
only against him boy his mouse
is sleeping
rook f7
push
here
dania getting tilted what is new
daniel playing alireza and he's tilted
wow
are we at the end of the world
25
it's almost works but then first of all
guys
let's go
you see
oh shoot shoot shoot runners are back
i was hoping for this in my only trap
but still i'm losing completely at 35.
it was like
it's not under this
wow
very cheap
probably i'm worse here now
stop the buy
yeah you guys it's on me
oh man why i'm so bad
dude i just played worst game of my life
crazy
i just got so lucky oh my god
oh that's utterly utterly undeserved
i totally underserved she took daniel
yeah
now either all right mr resign after a
mouse slip
still think that all right
that was absurd bishop d4 bishop e3
mouth slip i need to be careful about
those
it keeps happening like i grabbed the
wrong piece and put it on a square it's
weird
anyways we'll deal with that later can
we kind of focus
you regretted that as soon as you said
it well you you hyped me up you know
oh my god that's crazy
that was a must-win and we delivered
95 before there was a bad move i don't
know
okay why don't i just go up here those
are five
um all right
all hands on deck let's take it
that was awesome no it was an awesome
comeback but it's so bad
the wind itself was not deserved
let's go here can't believe i
still can't believe i won that
rebecca
okay we need to reroute this guy this
baby boy
thank you rockstar as charlie says
i'm not sure who's i'm probably losing
actually
she's just going to pile up on the each
he phone the worst possible way i think
against this structure yeah i will draw
my challenge to magnus because at this
point
i don't have much time until like 30
minutes or so
and i blundered
that was a very bad game crazy yeah but
now i have oh
crazy oh my god what is wrong with me i
think i missed these
oh my god that was such a bad game
another must win
no e45 is unplayable against him
karo khan maybe
i'm not trash talking i'm just saying
like that destruction should have gone
h3
i mean it's crazy using all the
subtleties easily he got just easily
mated in the h fight oh that's no i
gotta go soon so
close to winning i mean no no
i will go here bishop g6
wait we didn't wait i didn't take on h3
shoot okay
okay that was it
i need a little bit more consistency in
my play
thank you verified one for the tier one
i appreciate it
my play has been a little bit better
than usual the only rise up it's still
completely unsatisfactory that's a pun
she probably blundered although he takes
this one
maybe he saw her who knows
well thanks
let's go okay bye
let's go c4 supporting the bishop and
yeah i wanted to provoke c6 actually
got this square please use it here
thanks
i can't really find anything worth
playing though let's just go here
like jim crossing rookie
that
yeah now i'm sliding into a bad position
again
do you get banned if you talk bad about
amazon on twitter
thank you 30 monatos for two months
against amazon or no bishop i'll play
what will i play no okay
that's pretty cool i just wanted to know
i don't know
of course but i'll tell you guys give it
uh
two years he'll be the best blitz player
in history
give him give him two years he'll be the
best blitz player in history
let's go here
thank you verizon vision vision none
the fly for the prime thank you for two
months sorry thank you so much
this is seven thank you the lost romeo
for three months thank you for so much
for three months
prime thank you hello sir hello chief
just look in your chain
don't call me charlie
95
push
here
push
wait that's the blunder right yeah of
course
i got so dumb
that is that is very i mean it's just
ridiculous
he has your room in 3d right now okay
completely outplayed him to him in that
position completely i'll play them
and then a stupid move does anyone know
where i can change this
thing so i can't primo um you should go
no um
blunder blunder one can't see anything
anymore
wait where is the primo one blunder
after another
[Music]
you're welcome
maybe i won't mouse flip this time ago
knight d2 is only move again he if he
doesn't okay now he knows it
castles is the move here but it's not
easy to see
because castle seems to blunder into
this
it should be three nights
no i always i mean i blunder recently
i've been wondering
non-stop some time no i saw he yeah
one after another afternoon used it
somewhere else
a never blunder well rarely blunders and
b
never fails to punish blunders ever so
castle sort of you see it in stark
relief
those knights are yeah foreign
gonna be the best in the world very
shortly
i think i'm going three i might maybe
i'll also get better
but
i know this is equal but i don't know
how to play this he goes into the
exchange response which now i know very
well so
no i'll i'll give up my gym title i was
like yeah i don't really need it
it's it's it's overstayed it's welcome
this isn't sprite
this is uh sparkling water
seven more viewers to reach thousands of
viewers let's go
you're hitting thousand viewers for
first time let's go seven more viewers
and we
reach there okay i want to limit his
knight so no knight e5
let's go rook c1
rookie one let's go rookie one
i don't know if he wants e5 or not
let's begin with this move let's see
let's play more flexibly i was gonna go
g5 but
okay allows d1 interesting
rook h1 now that doesn't look right
and that doesn't look right is there
anything that looks good here
not really i'm just let's go ahead and
we had a thousand people
maybe he goes ricky you two and blonders
a piece i think our peak viewers is
seven thousand
without raid and chess tv or anything
so hey tribeca castle how are you
um
let's go knight d2 it was 92 000 okay
okay i have an idea let's go up to d3 so
i can go to e3 later
you can give me a track obviously but i
don't think it's scary
e5 i thought i have rookie three oh
clearly a oh knight c4
wait i can actually just take it it
should be fine
yeah okay maybe now rookie three no but
then he goes
okay wait wait yeah no i have to
it is first time i think kind of tribeca
is
[ __ ] in the chat let's go
radical f5
nights try to limit his night
we want to play on them i was thinking
maybe we and nikola could
they um deposit rushing
the survival that would be nice i think
we can reach 200
in one day
i could try becca for 20 gifted thank
you so much
private go for 20 gift itself
no okay whatever
wait oh my god what oh my god
i'm just so dumb
what am i doing
yes let's go thank you terrible again
for 20 gifted amazing thank you so much
this is just it's just uh it's just a
conspiracy of
sort steph three wins
this is this is what i expected when we
started of course
wait i'm up six four wow i'm up six to
four
that's crazy i thought i'm down four to
three that's how it usually is with him
i was not paying attention even to the
result
i thought i'm down four to three i'm off
six to four crazy
okay i'm not playing bad then moves why
did i have to go to e1
or just make a drop give me seven
so sick of my own play
make a goddamn draw
what do you guys think if me and hikaru
sit and think about survival
how much can we reach this you guys sing
in one day like say like three hours
can we reach 100 in three hours i'm just
taking it now from now on i'm just going
to take a draw first opportunity i get
no no no more of this
trying to play for a win against these
people it's not worth it
142 yeah
um
i think we can reach hundred in three
hours
on who's the count though i mean who
cares
cannot say how frustrating this is okay
let's go h3 to stop
stop on g4 maybe
i literally don't care here
975
reach 1k viewers let's go
i'm gonna try something first time wait
is this a sack
wow this is a sack
this guy just gives pieces like
random i mean dania is amazing
okay if i take take here this is an
important game in a way
stabilize you take i could take here
first of all and i'm completely winning
but take the queen g5 take take engage
one
okay not so easy
rookie four we shot d3
we're h4 okay let's go here
thank you annoying mouse for here come
on
the unknowing mouse
this looks like a pretty good position
but here
but not that that's
been particularly helpful so far
no no it's not actually not
okay let's get the king out of the way
it's afraid
there's just no opponent more
frustrating than ellie reza ferrugia
bar none
oh okay yeah this is me
yeah this is just me
and no opponent more fun to be sad
so let's go keep coming back for more
like up six to five at late
95
i'm surprised he goes for this position
i wonder what he sees
here maybe white is slightly better who
knows
okay so we want to go f65
thank you itchy badger thanks for the
support guys i really appreciate it
sorry this was a frustrating series
let's try try to win another one
yeah sorry guys for the frustration
today
i'm putting it all on the line
[Music]
we will try everything single weekend
yeah that was a very pretty sequence
actually
very pretty
let's have distant fire good to see you
okay so i think we want to take and open
the position now but i'm not sure
maybe this was about i don't know thank
you for the sub thank you for this up
if i go here this gun is for him to go
here
so d4 i'll take it and go knight f5
if king h1 i can play knight f3 i can
also play knight g4
with big threats on f2
well this is not good i mean this is
clearly not that good for him
okay we can try this going to play
you guys can watch the stream side by
side obviously that's a good way to get
entertained
watch both of our perspectives although
both of us i imagine are focused
queen d6 is a friend
he said sag that's funny
okay
well we gotta win the exchange
truth be told this is not that good
let's go with the rook
um i'm not sure what i want to do here
no let's not bother let's just take it
okay knight g5 could be scary in such
situations
why do you stream so late i don't know
it should change yeah
how do i do this
but it's fine i'm playing okay i mean
um okay i'm freezing five is fine
i will take six to five
we'll go here
okay i will give him a
simple here
here
goes there it should be three as a
thread obviously there should be five
there they're there
maybe first
now
was probably good
so
i should
[Music]
yeah okay all right
okay i'm going to play not great but
we'll we'll take it
okay i'm going to play better let's go
okay let's try to win another one get
back on top
i will play a little more serious
hmm that's a very strange remote
i see what he wants let's play e5
the low time sound tell me about it that
stresses me out like nothing else
okay we gotta move somehow he got the
better of me there
thank you the skinner too no i'm much
worse essentially
okay we need to play super accurately
here
what to do why nepo is not online
anymore i think he has
he's preparing for candidates it starts
in three days i have some queen sacks
but none of them work
shelby g4
let's try this what's up j baba
grand master chipotle
um all right that's not terribly scary i
think
well actually no it kind of is all right
lyrica's sicilian is really annoying
now i can repin
and now we can go here for example
prepare some f4 nonsense wait we have
more down there
no m4 is interesting in such positions
1958 he's playing so
quickly
all right let's try to get the knight
around here
gotta play much faster than i am let's
take and go knight before
knight t4 okay i'm surprised
he allowed me to take
okay he just wants to flag me at this
point i can't blame him
now i get my bishop
in a very nice place jesus this is like
the best game ever played
that's crazy it was there okay okay
he's playing so fast and accurate right
now it's pretty sick
95 i think i take take
maybe not
okay that's a good move what i'm
complimenting him
don't do what i'm saying no i'm saying
he literally is playing amazing this
game
i mean it i absolutely mean it
let me sack the exchange here okay so he
goes there
set the exchange there there there
let's see okay here
there okay how do we make a draw
now we don't want to okay let's go there
i mean i'm singing yeah that's gonna be
very hard
it's probably a draw objectively but
i've got no time
good day
let's put this guy here
we'll do that
that's probably not a good move
objectively
i can push the pawn there that was the
idea
okay that fond's the right color
yeah it should be win
yeah this is winning
like him you know why should i flag him
i will win
that's when i'm getting ready to i don't
do
dirty flag
no it's well done this is very well done
you ever see me
dirty flag someone no yeah all done hold
on
actually a completely insane quality of
play let's put d4
and e5 no way yeah
okay i gotta go very shortly also i
can't play even fast with the mouse i
mean
crazy some people are claiming i'm
flagging people
i can't even play fast this mouse i kill
rare field one for the tier one last i
don't think it was a drop that was two
years ago i think
once initially i think it was already
lost
let's go c3 i'm pretty sure it was
already lost actually
thank you passer
thank you for the gift
here i don't know if it is theory but i
think it's good
i'm not sure what to do here what if i
take and go queen a5
you know then it takes actually played
570 bullet games in last
five days seriously that's crazy
i played 570 bullet games right
i think that's true yeah yeah
i i i i messed up
somewhere but i'm not sure where oh
crazy let's go queen a4
now he's playing instantly
and of course finding everything
pretty usual thank you trivia for prime
subscribing is the price this is our
opening disaster
if i take he's planning to take
you stay on my mind i will take
this body here
let's try to castle along and swindle
him but
it's not going to happen it's impossible
in such a position
hmm
we need three rookie one
it's not losing i think it's close to
equal uh but
i think it's only if you know how to
play it's definitely not close to losing
and that's
maybe slight edge for white but
practically speaking it's very hard to
play it's very good for white
i don't think i have any problem
and i if you don't know any theory like
me
you're working
wow king g2 i mean that's just like
that's a move nobody would ever play at
that time
but is that even good not sure
i could spare
yeah his accuracy is never really below
90. if i stop nail baiting you will too
uh if understood
no the line is not bad but the line
itself is not bad i've been
successful in blitz but but um okay
yeah but like in in blitz it's very it's
very difficult if you don't know the
theory
one and i thought i could go 95 maybe
thank you for five dollars who knows
who knows those there 94 94.
oh my goodness what an insane move you
have a friend who bites your nails okay
psychic man
give one eight and gives nothing
oh okay
i wonder what the accuracy was for that
one
looks very good
how did he not bring can you explain how
that works it's it
this always happens he'll pre-move like
four or five and then the moment i
attack his queen
he's not he has some primoz
it's insane go here
what was his accuracy on that one i'm
just curious
i just i don't understand how it's
possible
90 no way i don't believe that that's
insane
89.3 is more like it yeah he's beatable
he makes mistakes but i'm playing so
poorly most of the time
but i can't punish any of it let's try
to try to go crazy
oh he had an ideator that's still pretty
crazy
oh my accuracy is horrible man
i gotta step up my game what can i say
horrific
94.98 well that's that's better
but still okay this is not very good
yeah
yeah bishop e3 is interesting i don't
see the reason not to move the king
he's gotten in trouble
yeah he's a freaking god
foreign
says if i don't win no one follow me
that's fair that's fair better
yeah queenie's six though
where's the win if he goes queen e6
do i not have mate there
wait do i know where is the maid
queen c4 i thought bishops before i
thought was made but it's not
okay okay okay everybody calm down
let's bring this boy in
but i will manage to lose this i think
if anybody will i will manage
is that cool thank you
want to do what to do
am i having so much difficulty here
i don't know what to do
knight g4 maybe like this simple
bishop h6 knight g7
we need six though six oh sorry sorry
wait what
really riley
what to do what to do where's the wind
where's the wind where's the wind
trying i'm trying i'm trying
i want to do what to do
no no no bishop g4 oh no oh my god i
plundered this
oh my goodness i oh
i'm so stupid i i saw it and then i
blundered it
oh my goodness i'm just such an idiot
all this for all this pressure
he's the luckiest bastard on earth
i've never seen anybody larger than all
the rest of some games
unbelievable
[Music]
not even that winning
i can't i don't understand how this is
possible
i mean that those positions there's no
maid it's like i've never seen anything
like it before
and of course i can't calculate anymore
so
that doesn't help
can we time i mean all you're saying is
tilt so you're not really adding to the
conversation my friend
how can that position not be made
how can how is that possible for this
position they're not to be made in this
position
insane no need to call anybody names
just
spamming the same word is not the best
thing to do
in a match like this
okay
[Music]
i don't know what's wrong oh my god
computer froze
sorry all right we're good my mouth
stopped working too
i thought it was my mouse
i gotta go anyway i gotta go anyway so
shortly
well yeah i mean of course i'd have to
freeze the wrong moment
now this is over i knew it's already
lost anyway even without them
good start to the match
justice prevailed in the end
the slump continues
there's some chances here i've seen some
counter play
if i had a little more time this time i
could have used it
the slump continues another day
will never end
my play was improved today for sure
definitely better than yesterday
oh
so
it is what it is don't you bastard that
side
ah what should we do um
okay i'm down for one last one if he has
time one last
one four this reminds you the nepo game
or maybe some 30 second just a couple
before i have to go
what about that yeah i see i'm done
i hope you guys enjoyed the match sorry
my play is just on hold you know my play
has been
very lackluster for a couple weeks now
tonight he was playing good
sound much better today for sure than it
was yesterday
he's done fair enough it's much better
today than it was yesterday but still
very far from satisfactory
good game of good games all right so i
really appreciate it yeah tough matches
today i mean diara vinali reza
i'm pretty drained and i've got 800
things to do
um and not enough time to do it in
all right well i expect to crush
everybody to be fair
so
yeah alright guys well thanks for the
support everybody really appreciate all
the subs
all the support doing uh these tough
matches
[Music]
you